>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Kevin Amer: OK.
Welcome back, everyone.
We are going to start session
five, the last session of the day.
This session is on
permanent exemptions.
And I'll just read the description.
This session will explore the
necessity, relevance and sufficiency
of the permanent exemptions to
the prohibition on circumvention
and will consider whether amendments
or additional exemption
categories may be advisable.
So to get started, I'd just like
to ask the panelists once again
to introduce themselves and
along with their affiliation.
>> June M. Besek: June Besek,
Kernochan Center for Law,
Media and the Arts at
Columbia Law School.
>> Gabe Cazares: Gabe Cazares,
Government Affairs Specialist,
National Federation of the Blind.
>> Krista L. Cox: Krista Cox,
with the Association
of Research Libraries.
>> Troy Dow: Troy Dow, with
The Walt Disney Company.
>> Harley Geiger: Harley
Geiger, with Rapid7.
>> Matt Williams: Matt Williams.
I'm here on behalf of
AAP, MPAA and RIAA.
>> James Love: Jamie
Love, James Love,
with Knowledge Ecology
International.
>> David Perry: David Perry,
with the law firm of Blank Rome,
on behalf of Doorman Products, Inc.
>> Chris Mohr: Chris Mohr, SIIA.
>> Maryna Koberidze: Maryna
Koberidze, no affiliation.
I'm here as a concerned member of
the public and IP law enthusiast.
Thank you.
>> Kevin Amer: And a
proud alum of our office.
So, welcome all.
So I thought we would proceed sort
of in two parts, first by looking
at the adequacy and
the functionality
of the current exemptions
and then turning to proposals
for additional permanent
exemptions and to get your thoughts
on whether any may be
necessary or advisable.
We're thinking of proceeding
a little bit differently
in this session.
As you know, a lot of the existing
permanent exemptions are specific
to particular types of uses and are
maybe more relevant to particular--
to certain of you than others.
So we may direct questions
specifically to individual people
to start out with, but everyone
obviously is welcome to weigh in
and in fact, we, you know,
we encourage you to do so.
So I wanted to start by talking
about the library exemption
under Section 1201(d).
We received a number of
comments on this exemption
from library associations.
I think the word useless came
up in one or two of them.
And so, if I could direct
this to you, Ms. Cox,
I just would be interested just sort
of generally in your perspective
on the current library exemption,
you know, if you could sort
of elaborate on why it may
not be as useful as hoped,
and any changes you
would like to see.
>> Krista L. Cox: Well,
I certainly think
that Section 1201(d) is not very
useful for libraries, archives
and educational institutions.
It's not actually an
exemption that we asked
for in the DMCA legislative hearings
and that whole process because it's
so narrowly drafted,
it's not an exemption
for any nonprofit library
or educational use.
It's not even an exemption for
any library or educational use
that is already granted
under, you know, Section 108
or granted under fair use.
It's so narrowly tailored to
only acquisition decisions.
And you can only use that
exemption for the time necessary
for an acquisition decision.
And it is our view that if
we are going out and looking
to make an acquisition, that whoever
is selling that book or that product
to us would be happy to open
up that digital lock for us
to make that determination.
We find that we are constantly using
every three years the rulemaking
process to pursue the exemptions
that we think are really necessary,
for example, to-- for
assistive technologies for those
that are blind, visually impaired or
print-disabled, for educational uses
of audiovisual materials.
So for us, those are the types
of uses that we would find--
that we need continually and that
would warrant a permanent exemption
versus the very narrow
exemption in 1201(d).
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
And so, just sort of in practice,
I mean, in your experience,
is the current exemption-- I mean,
it sounds like the answer is no.
Do you know of many examples
of librarians making
use of that exemption?
>> Krista L. Cox: I don't, because
I don't know of content providers
who hand something over to
a library locked and say,
do you want this product,
it's locked.
No, I mean, it just-- for
purposes of acquisitions,
normally the content providers
are happy to unlock it for us
as we make a decision in purchasing.
>> Kevin Amer: OK.
Now-- Oh, sorry.
Go ahead.
>> Regan Smith: Can I ask what are
your thoughts about reforming it
to track the contours of 108
which is different, I will say,
than some of the petitions for
exemptions in the rulemaking.
>> Krista L. Cox: I think that--
I mean, I think that
there are certainly areas
where it would be useful
to amend 1201 in order
to accommodate what's
allowed under 108.
But there are, of course, other
uses as well that we would support.
>> Kevin Amer: Oh, sorry.
So-- Well yeah, so I think
that was one proposal.
I mean, I know in our comments
from the American Association
of Law Libraries, there
was a recommendation
that a permanent exemption
be created for any use
that was permissible under 108.
I assume-- Is that something
that you're recommending as well
or do you think that the,
you know, the exemptions
that you've petitioned
for pertaining
to motion pictures are sort
of a more pressing concern?
>> Krista L. Cox: Can we have both?
>> Kevin Amer: Well--
>> Krista L. Cox: No.
I mean, yes.
I think that, you know, having--
expanding it to apply to Section
108 would be very, very helpful.
And, you know, I think this just
highlights a fundamental flaw
of the 1201 process that,
you know, has been talked
about in these roundtables, that
it's not linked to infringement.
And it's, you know, from the
perspective of our libraries,
who really do want to follow the
law and, you know, ensure that--
simultaneously ensuring that
we are fulfilling our mission,
that it doesn't really make sense
to have these exemptions granted
under Section 108 or be
allowed under fair use.
But then, you can't
actually do it just
because we've moved
into a digital world.
>> Kevin Amer: Are there
any other views on sort
of the advisability
of-- oh, I'm sorry.
I didn't even see.
Mr. Williams?
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Regan Smith: We're mic-less.
>> Matt Williams: Oh,
mine just came on.
OK, great.
>> Kevin Amer: OK.
>> Matt Williams: Thank you.
>> Kevin Amer: Oh yeah, if we could
just ask if you're not speaking
to turn off your microphone?
Thank you.
>> Matt Williams: Thank you.
I did see that the library community
is not finding the existing
exemption helpful.
And it sounds to me like that's
because the market is
working really well.
As she said, copyright
owners are more than willing
to give test access to libraries
so that they can sample the works
and decide whether to buy them.
So, I think that's a good news
story, not a bad news story
that we need to worry about.
I, in the comments, saw that in
replace of the permanent exemption,
what the libraries seem to be asking
for is all non-infringing
uses exemption.
And we've talked in other
panels about why there are a lot
of dangers associated with
those types of proposals
and why 1201(a) was designed not
to necessarily protect only
exclusive rights under section 106,
but also to provide a right of
access that is very important
and that needs to be preserved.
When you get to the slightly
narrower approach of just--
for 108 covered uses, I doubt
that that is going to go very far
in terms of reducing the number
of exemptions that libraries seek
because what I often read,
at least, is that libraries
and others are unhappy with the
scope of 108 as it currently exists.
And so, they would rather point to
Section 107 for most of the things
that they want to do, in which
case you either get back to a kind
of pseudo all non-infringement
uses-type of approach or you end
up needing, even if you
cover all 108 activity,
for people to come back every
three years and make new requests.
So, I'm not sure that that would
have a very effective impact.
I think what will have a
more effective impact is
that if the more streamlined
approach to renewals
that was discussed yesterday is
adopted in some workable format,
the need to make permanent
these types
of exemptions becomes
a lot less important
and you actually preserve the
ability to have some confidence
of renewal, but you also
preserve the flexibility
of having the rulemaking there so
that if someone needs something new,
they don't have to go all
the way back to Congress.
Again, they can come to you.
Thanks.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Ms. Besek?
>> June Besek: Well, specifically
with respect to an exception
for 108 activities, I can't help but
wonder why the libraries need it now
when they haven't made such a
request, not necessarily with regard
to all 108-- specific 108 activities
over the last several years.
It seems to me that if the
structure were that deficient,
they would have consistently asked
for that exemption,
and it's not there.
So I'm not sure there's
really a basis.
The second point I want to make
is I think Section 108 is broader
than people might realize.
I was on the Section 108
group, as were others here.
And, you know, it gives libraries
a fair amount of flexibility
with respect to providing
copies for users, for example.
And so, I don't think
that we should assume
that that would be
a narrow exception.
And I think without-- I
think it is really akin
to the no non-infringing uses, you
know, rather that you should be able
to circumvent for any
non-infringing use or any fair use.
I think it falls in that
category and I would be reluctant
to see that without more.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Ms. Cox, would you like
to respond to that?
>> Krista L. Cox: So of course, the
libraries-- Mr. Williams is correct,
we do support the Unlocking
Technology Act,
which would tie infringement
to circumvention.
But as a next best option, you
know, we do very much believe
that permanent exemptions are
warranted in certain cases.
For example, for assistive
technologies for the blind,
library services, authorized
entities that, you know,
were often providing
accessible formats for the blind,
also for the audiovisual exceptions
for educators and students
at our colleges and universities,
for K through 12 educators.
These are all exemptions that
we have supported in the past.
And in the most recent rulemaking
cycle, the NTIA recommendation
to the Register in that report said
that they acknowledge the concerns
by the rights holders who oppose
these exemptions, but that,
you know, that emphasizing
that these exemptions don't
legalize copyright infringement
and that the record doesn't
show that the previous grants
of similar exceptions
have led to piracy.
So I think in those cases,
it makes a lot of sense
to move towards a permanent
exemption,
to expand our current 1201(d)
exemption to include the activities
that are really important
to us, like these exemptions
that we request every time.
I think the Library Copyright
Alliance joined four different
proposals for exemptions
for audiovisual classes
in this past rulemaking cycle.
And, you know, it seems like
that that just keeps expanding.
And so, I think having a permanent
exemption that is broad enough
to cover these areas would make a
lot more sense than us having to go
through this every time, especially
when there isn't any evidence
that infringement occurs
in having these exemptions.
>> Regan Smith: Can you
speak to Mr. Williams' point
that perhaps streamlining the
renewal would serve a great deal
of your concerns, while still
sort of leaving the door open
in case there were changed
circumstances in the market
or something or some reason,
you know, to sort of not etch it
in statutory stone
and make it permanent?
Could you live with that instead?
>> Krista L. Cox: Well,
I certainly think
that streamlining the
process would of course help.
But I would have to
see what the contours
of that streamlined process would
look like because, you know,
previous rulemaking
cycles, of course,
were I think much less
involved than they are today,
where you have a 400-page report
from the Copyright Office.
I think that if there is
a, you know, presumption of
or an automatic renewal
unless there is evidence
of changed circumstances, that
would certainly be helpful.
But what would be even
better, of course,
is that if there's a permanent
exemption where, you know,
time and time again, the Copyright
Office is granting exemptions
for persons who are blind
or disabled, for educators
and educational institutions,
for students in college
and universities.
I think where there's
strong evidence
that there has not been infringement
as a results of these exemptions,
it just makes sense to
make them permanent.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Could I just follow up
on the 108 question?
We received some comments
that talked about the need
to circumvent for-- of libraries
to circumvent for, for example,
preservation purposes and
they used the example of works
in obsolete format, which may
include TPMs in obsolete format.
I'm just wondering if you could
sort of elaborate on that.
And I wasn't totally clear
whether that sort of issue goes
to access controls or whether
the issue is copy controls.
In other words, if
you have, you know,
if a library receives a collection
of VHS tapes or something,
is the issue with respect
to preservation
that the library can't access
the works or is it more
that there is a copy control
which would prevent
you from digitizing it?
>> Krista L. Cox: Well,
I think with the VHS,
it would be a copy
control mechanism,
not an access control mechanism.
I think my colleague, Brandon
Butler, who actually works
in a library may have more
information on this issue.
>> Kevin Amer: OK.
OK. No, that's fine.
Well, Mr. Dow?
>> Troy Dow: Thank you.
So, just a couple of points.
I served with June on
the Section 108 Committee
and I had a similar reaction to the
proposal that there'd be some sort
of exception that would apply to
Section 108 covered activities
and that they apply to such
a broad range of activities,
including things like
interlibrary loan, copies for users.
I know that in the course
of our discussions there
in the Section 108 group, we
talked extensively about the fact
that copies for users for
private study was contemplated
by many libraries to include
loaning of materials and providing
of materials for personal review,
including the loaning of movies
and things like that
for personal review.
And so, the notion that
you would have an exemption
that would allow you to
circumvent copy protection,
to provide unencrypted copies
of expressive works as part
of interlibrary loan
or as part of copies
for users I think would
be of concern to us.
On the issue of not having
evidence of infringement,
one of the concerns throughout
even with rulemaking processes,
it's very, very difficult to tie
resulting acts of infringement
to the particular uses that
are being made pursuant
to the exemptions, right?
And so, if you have an exemption
to allow people to make copies
for a variety of uses,
tying then downstream--
if the result is that that
allows for circumvention
to release unencrypted copies
of works then it's very hard
to tie the downstream
copies of unencrypted copies
to the first initial
copy that was made.
So, while there's not an abundance
of information in the record
to show infringements, it's actually
really hard to say what the impact
of that is in the marketplace.
The last thing I'll say is
that in terms of Section 108,
the other thing that
I think we learned
in that process was it's very--
that's a section that is
sort of technologically
and marketplace-dependent.
And part of the reason we
were gathered together to talk
about Section 108 was because
technology had eclipsed the statute.
And Congress had attempted
to make some updates
in the context of the DMCA.
And even those updates have been
eclipsed by time and by technology.
And so, I think in
that sort of context,
in the types of things you're
talking about in 108 for things
like preservation, there's a benefit
to having a rulemaking process
that can respond to those
changes in the marketplace,
to the specific technologies
that are being used,
to the specific concerns about what
the impact of allowing circumvention
in those circumstances would be,
that would not only
streamlined access
to those exemptions along the
lines that were discussed but also
to have exemptions that are
tailored to the particular needs
and to the particular concerns and
much better than you would be able
to do with a permanent exception
that you might find
yourself looking at,
very much like 108,becomes
quickly outdated.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Love?
>> James Love: Thank you very much.
If the permanent exceptions are by
statute only and the statute sort
of sets out all the conditions,
I think that the problem
in the past is you end up
with a fairly narrow statute
that is frustrating for
people who are supposed
to be the intended
beneficiary of the statute.
A better approach, in our mind,
is if the statutory
mandates an exception
but permits the Copyright Office
to provide more information
about the contours of the exemption
at a later date, like so for example
if the statute-- let's
take the issue of that uses
for people who are blind.
You know, if it was to address the
obligations in the Marrakesh Treaty
for people with disabilities.
If the mandate was broad but there
was some sort of understanding
that there could be, at some point,
more contextual information
provided, if necessary,
by the Copyright Office down the
road, it might be a better situation
than trying to spell out
every particular issue
that you might want
to do by statute.
Another thing I think
that's important--
I mean, we think that the idea of
more or less permanent exceptions--
I think permanent is a funny
word because nothing's really,
even in a statute, permanent.
So, I think what you're
talking about is durable
and persistent exceptions.
And so, I think the Copyright
Office surely should be able to do--
you know, the three-year
thing I think is a mistake.
I think a lot of people have
talked about that in other panels.
One thing-- One of the reasons that
there's a high cost of developing
and implementing both the
tools to use the exception and,
as important I think, the
standards and the best practices
for implementing exceptions.
Now, if you want to have a
conversation, for example,
among authorized entities for people
that are blind or you want to talk
about archivists or you want to talk
about maybe about auto-mechanics
or whatever group you want to
have, for them to sort of sort
out the problems of the
different stakeholders
so that they're not just
looking at their own interests,
but they're looking at the interests
of third parties that are affected
by the policies that
are implemented.
That can be a pretty
complicated thing.
And then you want to, you
know, and then you have
like a small enough number of
people, like the number of people
in this room, can kind of figure
out what that rule should be.
And then, you want to like educate
like thousands of people, you know,
as to how to sort of
use that standard and so
that they do it in
an appropriate way.
And then, you sort of say, but
this whole exercise is going
to be revisited three
years from now.
I mean, this kind of defeats the
idea that you're really serious
about doing it in a thoughtful
way, where you have buy-in
and implementation
that's really consistent.
So I think that one of the
reasons for the more persistent
and durable exceptions is the fact
that it really is time-consuming
and costly to design
the tools for exceptions
and to implement them appropriately.
Thank you.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Williams, did you have--
>> Matt Williams: Just a quick
point to go back to something
that Troy Dow said on
evidence of harm from any
of the existing exemptions,
he's absolutely right.
It's almost impossible for us to
collect data to show that someone
who used the exemption ended
up circulating pirate
copies on the Internet.
On the other hand, in
every cycle I think
since the AV works exemptions have
been in existence, we have pointed
to examples in the
proponent's comments of uses
that we think are likely
to be infringing.
They are not uses that my
clients have had any interest
in pursuing litigation over.
And calculating the actual harm
involved is quite difficult.
But, I just wanted for the record
to note that we have each cycle come
across uses that the
proponents have said are examples
of how they're using the exemptions
and our response has been, well,
some of these are actually
probably unlawful.
>> Kevin Amer: Great.
Thank you.
I want to go back to Ms. Cox,
and then I think we're going
to move to the next topic.
>> Krista L. Cox: Just because
108 has been such a focus
of this discussion so far, you know,
I just want to say that, you know,
there have been some criticisms
that 108 is out of date
and therefore libraries
just look at fair use.
And while it's certainly true
that fair use is critical
to libraries, we do
use 108 every day.
I mean, I talk to-- any librarian
that I talk to, they say,
of course, 108 is still relevant.
It's still something we use.
Is it, you know, as
good as fair use?
Probably not, because fair use
is adaptable and, you know,
it is flexible enough to
accommodate these new technologies.
But 108 is not an obsolete statute.
And just with respect to
whether it's hard to get evidence
of downstream uses, while I
acknowledge that, yes, you know,
Mr. Dow and Mr. Williams may be
correct that it can be difficult
to trace back exactly where
an infringing copy came from,
I certainly hope that you're
not suggesting that libraries
and educational institutions
are using this exemption
and passing out infringing copies.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
So I think now we're
going to move to talk
about the reverse engineering,
encryption research
and security testing exemptions.
As you may know, in the
2015 recommendation,
the Office found a
compelling case that 1201(f),
(g) and (h) are inadequate to
accommodate their intended purposes.
So, I just would like to
start with a general question.
I'd like to ask your views as to how
these provisions might be amended
to more effectively facilitate
legitimate reverse engineering
activities and security research.
I think this may be particularly
relevant to Mr. Geiger and Mr. Mohr.
But others, of course, are
welcome to comment as well.
>> Chris Mohr: Sure.
Thanks. Well, just a couple
of preliminary points.
Essentially, from our
perspective, we believe we don't--
I'm not sure we share
the Office's conclusions
on this particular point.
We believe that the current statute
is working, that it can work.
Let me just address
a couple of things.
I mean, one of the things
that I have heard today
that probably would
cause my members a bit
of heartburn is some suggestion,
maybe implicit, maybe not,
that software is let's say a
second class copyright citizen.
And that is something that
we wholeheartedly reject.
And we heard that,
I think, in some--
as if one can separate the
function from expression easily.
I really-- I have looked
at a decent number
of cases examining these issues
and that's not an easy line.
And it hasn't been an easy line
basically for a long, long time.
And it's true not only with
respect to computer programs,
but it's also true with respect
to cheerleader uniforms and plays
and all kinds of idea expression.
It's the same line that's
expressed in different ways.
And it's a really fuzzy one.
With respect to the
exemptions themselves, I mean,
we believe the reverse
engineering exemption is adequate.
With respect to security testing,
our members have relationships
with the security testing industry.
If there are areas in which
voluntary agreements may be useful
to kind of allay Section
1201 concerns,
we're certainly open
to discussing those.
But at this time, we don't see
any need to open up the statute.
>> Regan Smith: Can I ask a more
targeted question about 1201(f),
the reverse engineering statute?
So, in the rulemakings and in
yesterday, we heard a lot about,
you know, how 1201 was not
intended to prevent, you know,
a lock-in effect for printers or
garage door openers or something.
And when I read 1201(f),
it says you can, you know,
circumvent for the
purpose of identifying
and analyzing elements necessary
to achieve interoperability.
Do you have an opinion on whether
it makes sense to reform 1201(f)
to include, you know,
things necessary
to enable interoperability?
And I think the Breaking Down
Barriers to Innovation Act,
you know, has some specific
language for that too.
I mean, what are your thoughts on
going beyond I guess identifying
and analyzing into helping
facilitate interoperability?
>> Chris Mohr: I think there's--
I think that if my
recollection is correct,
and it very well may not
be, that this particular--
that the standard in 1201(f)
came out of existing case law.
I can't recall which case.
I would have concerns about
the breadth of the concept
of facilitating interoperability
covers I think a wealth of sins.
And many of them would-- could lead
to pretty bad things
for a lot of my members.
So, I'm not-- color me skeptical
about that particular proposal.
>> Kevin Amer: Mr. Geiger?
>> Harley Geiger: Thanks.
So unsurprisingly, we disagree that
the statute is currently working
with regard to security research.
The temporary exemption
is a big deal for us.
It is extremely helpful.
But that aside, in talking
about the permanent exemption,
as it stands right now, 1201does
chill very important security
research, research that will
help prevent harm to individuals
and it will help prevent
breach of sensitive data.
And we gave you an
example in our comments.
We have a researcher
that is employed
by Rapid7 who is a diabetic.
He wants to research his own
insulin pump, but was prevented
from doing so, prior to
the temporary exemption,
because of 1201 of the DMCA.
In addition, a lot of
independent security researchers,
folks that are not necessarily
employed by us but that we work
with to help improve our own
security products, they are chilled.
That is, they don't engage in the
research to begin with or many
of them actually receive
cease-and-desist letters
that reference the DMCA.
This is again prior to
the temporary exemption.
So we don't think that it works
and we think that this issue
of security research in software
is becoming a lot more important.
As discussed previously, we are
seeing this explosion of software,
both in the physical
world and virtually.
And there are a lot
more security flaws
than there are people to fix it.
And in many cases,
manufacturers either don't know
about the software
flaws or they turn--
they're willfully ignorant of them.
Part of the problem with
voluntary agreements,
and this goes to the
requirement of authorization
in the permanent exception, is
that it hampers independence.
It means that the manufacturers
themselves get
to control completely how the
security research takes place
and what the publication is like.
And if you're a manufacturer
that doesn't support
independent security research
or if you are a manufacturer
that has something to hide,
as Volkswagen, for example,
might then that will make the
research a lot less effective
and not as independent.
There are also several
other problems
with the permanent exception,
one of which is this requirement
that it violate no other law.
The CFAA is very, very broad.
It's very ambiguous.
It is the subject right now of
some pretty sharp circuit splits.
So you're importing a lot of the
ambiguity from these other laws
into 1201, laws that have
their own chilling problems
and doing it largely for
non-copyright reasons.
There's also a part of the
permanent exemption that says
that the information derived from
the research cannot be maintained
in such a way that could
facilitate infringement
or violation of another law.
Well, what happens if
you're a security researcher
and you've contacted
the manufacturer
about a problem in their product?
They do nothing and the standard
practice is that eventually,
you will make that
disclosure public.
>> Regan Smith: Well, doesn't the
statute sort of contemplate by that
by saying it's a factor
that should be considered?
And maybe in that specific use case,
it would make sense to not stick it
with the manufacturer,
but to go broader?
>> Harley Geiger: Absolutely.
The fact that it's just
a factor as opposed
to an outright requirement, sure.
But both factors are cutting against
the security researcher, right?
One is, you know, if
they've publicly disclosed it
and then others can use
that for nefarious purposes,
which is part of the point, right?
Part of the reason why
you publicly disclose is
to encourage a manufacturer
to actually correct their flaw
if they haven't been previously.
And then, the second was
whether the information is solely
for the purpose of
benefiting the manufacturer,
the owner of the computer system.
And a lot of times, security
researchers are doing this
for the benefit of the public,
not necessarily the owner
of the computer system.
I want to make three
other points really quick
because we've talked about--
>> Regan Smith: Right, keep it quick
because we'll have
follow-up questions.
>> Harley Geiger: I'll
talk about it quickly.
We talked about this in
previous panels, right?
So this idea of an
embedded software exception
or in the temporary exception, we're
talking about consumer devices.
These lines are blurring, right?
And things that are embedded
in software now may not be--
or embedded in devices now may
not be in devices in the future,
consumer devices, likewise.
Security researchers work
on more than just devices.
They work on networks.
They work on completely
virtual software.
Then what counts as a
consumer device is also
in many cases a business device
or is used by infrastructure.
And we want to encourage that
kind of security research.
So, thank you.
>> Kevin Amer: I'd like
to ask you a follow-up
and then others can
weigh in as well.
It's sort of a more
general question.
I mean, you mentioned
the multifactor framework
that both 1201(g) and
(j) provide for.
As a general matter, do
you sort of think that type
of framework is helpful,
where there's sort
of a multifactor analysis that
a court can take into account?
Or does that in itself provide--
sort of reduce some of the certainty
as to what's permitted and
under what circumstances?
>> Harley Geiger: It
absolutely reduces the certainty.
And in our opinion, we'd prefer
to see a blanket security research
exception for things that are not--
just for the sole purpose of
improving the safety and security
and correcting software flaws.
So, I would kind of cut it off right
after the definition
of security testing.
So in many cases, we
are seeing agencies move
to protect the other types
of equities that you see
in the permanent exception,
like privacy, like safety.
The NHTSA, the Transportation
Security Agency as well as the FTC
and others like they are already
moving to protect against hacking
that in a way that violate privacy.
We've got laws for that.
So it's unclear to us why 1201 ought
to be the vehicle, so to speak,
to prevent those types
of activities.
I will also say that when it comes
to trafficking, you know, we--
because we are a penetration
testing company,
we actually do use software.
We even market software that
can be used to circumvent.
And some of that includes
circumventing passwords
or brute forcing encryption.
Companies, this is very valuable
to them because they want
to know what flaws
they're susceptible to.
And so, we have to
traffic in that software
in order to run our business.
And we work with security
researchers
that send us updates and exploits.
They traffic in the
circumvention tools to us
so that we can keep our
products up to date.
So this is an important
component of security research.
And I will just-- I'm saying
this because I wouldn't want
to see trafficking fall by
the wayside if we're talking
about reforming the
permanent exemptions.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Williams?
>> Matt Williams: Thank you.
I'm primarily here to talk about
books and music and movies.
So, some of these issues are
to a certain degree separate
from those interests.
However, I do have some concerns
that if you start taking a lot
of the limitations out of some
of these permanent exceptions,
that there will be
unintended consequences
that will impact the industries
that I'm here representing.
I went through the
statute this morning
and had the pending
legislation and started marking
through the portions
that would be deleted.
And a lot of the safeguards that
Congress decided it made sense
to put in there are being taken out.
And some of that might be for
perfectly legitimate purposes.
I can't speak to that.
But some of it could
cause some harm.
And so, I'm skeptical of whether
it's necessary because usually
when Congress decides to amend
an exception that's already
in the statute, there's
a number of cases
that have come through the courts.
They've either come out the wrong
way or there's a lot of indecision
between them when you compare them.
And I don't think that's
been the case here.
There's been a lot of
debate in the rulemaking
about what the existing exemptions
would allow or not allow.
But I haven't seen much in the
way of litigation to point to.
So, I think to take it to
Congress without those types
of badly decided cases, it
might be a bit of a stretch.
I mean, I can think back
to when the last sentence
of Section 107 was added
and I think that was 1992.
There was five, six, seven I
think unpublished works cases
that took place before the Congress
decided we should add this sentence
that just basically says if
it's an unpublished work,
it might still be a fair use.
>> Regan Smith: Well, can I
ask you a follow-up question?
Because I, you know,
I take your point
about treading lightly
on statutory reform.
But we do have this
rulemaking process
where if the permanent
exemption isn't working,
perhaps you're not seeing litigation
but you are seeing petitions
before the Copyright Office.
And the security testing
might be such an example
where they said the requirement
that there's authorization
from the owner is not
working for us.
Could you grant us a
different exemption?
I think in prior rulemakings,
we saw that more specific
for certain devices.
But there's sort of a repeat echo of
security research being something,
you know, if properly defined,
that might be permissible
through the exemption process.
I mean, would you oppose maybe not
crossing out all of the statute,
but for example, that specific--
you know, could you speak to
specific reform proposals,
the requirement of
authorization being one of them?
>> Matt Williams: I guess I
would say again that I think
that the easier and preferable
route to addressing those issues
that have already been
raised in the rulemaking is
to do the streamlined renewal
process as opposed to taking this
to Congress and asking them
to rewrite the statute.
One, because I am worried that there
will be unintended consequences,
but two, because I also think it's
such a difficult task to draft it
in such a way that no one who's
writing a law review article is
going to be able to come
up with a hypothetical case
that would come out the wrong way.
And then, people are
going to have to come back
and present issues
to you guys anyway.
So, I'm not so sure that trying
to rewrite it will actually fix the
problem of people needing to bring
to your attention issues
that are of concern to them.
I'm not ready to go through
line by line on the things
that have been proposed to be
taken out and give you a position
for my clients on each one of them.
But the things that concerned
me were the completely striking
out the factors to be considered.
As you said, they're just
factors to be considered.
Violations of other laws in
the context of these things
that also I think is
something that would have
to be thought about very carefully.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr.--
>> Matt Williams: I'm sorry.
I had one last thing that I
originally intended to say.
I apologize.
>> Kevin Amer: Sure.
>> Matt Williams: One thing I would
just ask you to do, if you do decide
to make recommendations in this
area, is if you'd go back to,
I think, 2010 and earlier rulemaking
decisions, there were issues
that came up about whether or not
you're entitled to access a movie
or another expressive work on
every different type of device
that you might want to access it on.
And the Office consistently
concluded that that's not the case,
that you don't have that right.
And I would just ask that if
you make changes in this area,
you take a look at those prior
decisions and just make sure
that you don't overrule
them essentially
without intending to do so.
Thanks.
>> Kevin Amer: Mr. Love?
>> James Love: When a-- There's
this automatic protection
that is associated with technical
protection measures right now
and we would prefer a system
where you'd apply, pay a small fee
and register the fact that you
have a technical protection measure
that you believe is entitled
or should be entitled
to legal protection.
And then, in the application
for doing so,
that you would describe how you
would address legitimate use
of users under exceptions, issues
of interoperability, perhaps issues
of sunsets on the protections
such as depositing unlock keys
for the Copyright Office.
And that you would
have terms of service
for the technical protection
measure which describes the impact
of the technical protections on what
you believe the user rights to be,
something along that lines
where you begin to sort
of treat the legal protections of
TPMs as a privilege, not a right.
And that you associate the privilege
with obligations on the person
who wants the state to
enforce the right for them,
recognizing that there
are these competing areas.
I think that that would-- Some of
the problems you have right now
of people are looking for permanent
exceptions and things like that.
I mean, sometimes it's because
the practices in the TPM, I think,
are so inconsistent
with public policy.
And it's just the-- it's
obvious that, you know,
you want to have some
carve-outs, some sort of it.
But people always raise
these issues like, well,
do you anticipate all the
problems and things like that.
I think just starting with the
idea that everything is protected
and you have to kind of
claw back the exceptions,
I think that creates
a lot of the problems.
If you sort of create the
environment where you have to sort
of make a case for the exceptions or
at least describe what you believe
that you've made the
case at a very minimum.
I think it begins to make the
whole process more manageable.
Also, I'm a little concerned
about the relationship
between trade agreements and what
you're doing in this proceeding
because you're-- the government is
involved in these trade agreements
where you're creating exceptions
about what we have to do
within the context of
the trade agreements.
And then they're creating
these investor state agreements
where people can bring
lawsuits against the--
or bring arbitrations against the
United States around those things
if their expectations aren't
met and things like that.
And I think that it would be
important for the Copyright Office,
to the extent that they're modifying
the rules or changing the rules
in this thing to also talk to the
United States Trade Representative
to make sure that they're
ensuring there's enough flexibility
in our agreements.
So if we change our philosophy about
how to do these technical locks
on things across a wide
range of industries,
not just the motion picture
industry or the book industry,
but in these areas that
involve automobiles
and consumer electronic devices
and all the other things affected
by the trade agreements,
that we're not in a situation
where you're trying to do one thing
where the United States
Trade Office--
Trade Representative is
making that difficult.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
And that actually sort of
anticipated a quick question.
So, are there any other examples
around the world of that sort
of system where, you know,
providing for a registration of TPMs
that you're aware of, and might
that implicate international
obligations of the US?
>> James Love: I think
right now, the closest model
for that would be the obligation
in the European Directive
that you have responded--
that you have obligations
to provide user rights in areas
that are part of the Directive.
Although I don't think it's
really spelled out very clearly.
And it's not the same as
sort of registering works.
I think though that the movement
against registration and copyright
across the board for
everything has been a mistake.
And I think the idea--
You could make an analogy
between the collateral damage
and harm that's been done
by having copyright
always-- I mean, everything--
>> Kevin Amer: I think we do--
>> James Love: -- on TPMs, this
is exactly the same problem.
It's just too sweeping.
And the combination of no obligation
on the person that's protected
and the fact that everything
is automatically protected,
those things collectively
create a lot of problems.
>> Kevin Amer: OK.
Thank you.
Mr. Geiger?
>> Harley Geiger: If I can
respond to a couple of things
that Mr. Williams said, part of
the reason that we don't see a ton
of litigation on 1201 in
security research is because,
for two reasons.
One, a lot of security
research is chilled and by 1201
so it actually doesn't get
to the litigation stage.
You know, so we'll see researchers
get cease-and-desist letters
and many times they
are not able to--
just don't have the expertise
to evaluate the legal claim.
And it just doesn't
go to litigation.
And then, second--
>> Regan Smith: Can I interrupt?
Is that-- Are you speaking
academically
or commercially or both?
Because I know in the rulemaking,
there seems to be sort of a divide
between the researchers for
research's sake and those
who are perhaps like
unaffiliated with an organization
and entities such as Rapid7.
>> Harley Geiger: So, for
folks that are unaffiliated
with an organization, they--
that's typically where the
cease-and-desist letters tend
to have the most impact.
If you're affiliated
with an organization,
then you have more resources to draw
on to evaluate your legal claims.
We play in both worlds.
We work a lot with independent
security researchers and try
to help be a steward
to that community.
But we also have our
own researchers.
And in cases where you have
an institutional affiliation,
a lot of times you just
see it ignored, right?
You just see-- you see the
cease-and-desist letter just kind
of ignored and sort of, well, if you
want to go to litigation over this
for real, then we'll do that.
And often, it doesn't
get to that stage.
Either way, the system is broken.
It may have made more
sense when it was enacted,
but as it is now, it's not working.
And we have-- I mean, cybersecurity
is a national priority.
Everybody recognizes that.
So why in the world would we wait
for bad cases to be litigated?
Two other points.
One is when it comes to not
violating any other law,
most of these other
laws, including the CFAA,
provide a private right of action.
It would seem odd to us to--
If the security research
is violating the CFAA,
why suddenly the permanent exception
protection should also fall away?
I mean, the punishments under CFAA
and other laws are
already relatively harsh.
So why add onto that with copyright?
I don't understand why
that would play into it?
And in addition, if it's a matter
of violating a licensing agreement,
then you do have recourse
through breach of contract to go
after the researcher there.
So, there are other
avenues that don't need
to necessarily rope in Section 1201.
>> Regan Smith: Can I ask
you a more targeted question?
Because I am hoping that these
roundtables sort of focuses
on potential areas of reform or
why they may not be advisable.
But, if you can trust
the encryption exemption
with a security testing exemption,
security testing exemption
I think needs to be
with the authorization
whereas with encryption,
you just need to make
a good faith effort.
And I know in the rulemaking,
we heard a lot
about the bug bounty programs or
front door policy or, you know,
ways in which there is sort of
an understood protocol or norms
or ethics that one might go
about in getting authorization.
If we made some revision to
call it a good faith effort
to get authorization as opposed
to a requirement, would
that help you out?
Would that be-- Do others
see problems with that?
>> Harley Geiger: So, unfortunately,
no, and for a couple of reasons.
It's definitely better
than a requirement.
And our standard practice is that we
do make a good faith effort to try
to contact the vendor,
whoever has the flaw.
And however, that is not--
not every manufacturer,
not every vendor actually has a
means of being able-- of contact.
And it is a policy that
in fact, the Department
of Commerce is working now
to try to get more adopted
through its multi-stakeholder
process.
But it is not really the norm
among industries right now.
And especially with the internet
of things, where we're seeing a lot
of companies that are
entering this computer space
and that maybe have not had a
lot of experience in it before,
they don't necessarily think to have
a vulnerability disclosure process.
And sometimes, it is very
difficult to get in touch with them.
The other problem with it--
>> Regan Smith: Well, in that case,
wouldn't you have made
your good faith effort or--
>> Harley Geiger: The
other problem is
that you don't always know
how to contact a vendor.
And some of the research that
we do is entirely online.
Some of it is automated.
We have a Project Sonar that
scans the entire Internet
in fact, does it every week.
And it is not always
feasible to contact the owner.
And it's often not
feasible to contact--
in the case of Project Sonar, where
we're scanning billions of devices,
there are millions of owners.
How do you contact all of them?
So, it's a best a practice
but it is not one
that I think the protection ought to
hinge on because it doesn't scale.
You know, you don't
always know the owner.
And even if you do know all
the owners, it doesn't scale
and it's not always the practice
of every manufacturer
to have an avenue.
And so, there is-- we've
experienced it, sometimes dispute
over whether the effort
was good enough.
>> Kevin Amer: I think
we'd like to go to Mr. Mohr
and then turn to the next topic.
[ Inaudible Discussion ]
>> Chris Mohr: Just a couple
of pretty quick points.
It's difficult for me to figure
out exactly what Mr.
Geiger's company does.
I don't know precisely what
they do and how they do it.
I would actually like to discuss
that with him afterwards,
in a nice way.
[ Laughter ]
>> Harley Geiger: Anytime, anytime.
I didn't want to take up time in the
panel, but I'd be happy to do that.
>> Chris Mohr: That would be useful.
I mean, just a couple of things.
Look, I mean, computer
networks existed
at the time this statute
was enacted.
Things are different now.
Certainly, the connectivity of
ordinary devices is expanding.
But our members certainly have--
are quite fond of the CFAA,
for example, in its current form.
And they are also quite fond of
the DMCA in its current form.
We-- Again, I mean, a lot of our--
I mean, a lot of our concerns are--
they may not be as much with
the legitimate activities
that Mr. Geiger's company does.
I mean, Sonar to me does
not sound like cracking.
It sounds like looking.
That's not something that
would necessarily implicate the
circumvention of a
technological protection measure.
And that's why-- I heard that
and that's why it struck me.
I was puzzled as to how the
DMCA would be implicated
in a situation like that.
>> Harley Geiger: So, I just
used Sonar as an example
of a large-scale security
research program.
And for the most part,
Sonar is just looking.
And we're looking at
ports and website--
or web router and website
connections that are not encrypted
or that have-- appear to have no
password protection and so forth.
And CFAA actually stops us from
going further in many cases.
But I'm mostly using that as
just an example for the problem
that you would have with scaling
for a large-scale research project
and something that you are able to
provide notice to individuals for.
>> Chris Mohr: And my concern
would be with a large-scale--
something dubbed a large-scale
research project that did much more
than let's say walk
around a neighborhood
and see whose blinds were down.
I mean, at that point,
we would have concerns.
We would have obviously
security concerns
and we would have potentially
infringement concerns as well.
>> Harley Geiger: Well,
I understand that.
I'm not really sure where the
copyright infringement concern is
there on your end.
But let's say that it is a
project like Sonar that is scanning
for routers that are
sending unencrypted traffic
or that there is a flaw in the
implementation of the encryption.
And so, you'd want to check to see
whether or not that flaw was present
in these routers all
around the world.
And I would guess that you could
probably find thousands of routers
at least that meet this flaw.
In order to find out that
they are in fact flawed,
then you may have to test it.
And I don't see where the problem is
for the availability of
the copyrighted work.
I don't see where the
copyright infringement is.
It'd be difficult to get
authorization in order to do
that beforehand or to inform
the router owners directly
after the fact.
And it would not be
covered currently by any
of the permanent exceptions.
And--
>> Kevin Amer: Yeah--
>> Harley Geiger: Sorry.
Go ahead.
>> Kevin Amer: Sorry.
You all are certainly welcome to
continue this after the roundtable.
I think we-- I think, did you
have one more question on--
>> Regan Smith: Yeah,
before we moved off that,
I just wanted to open it up to
anyone else who wanted to comment
about these three permanent
exemptions and specifically the one
for interoperability, 1201, if
anyone had thoughts on that.
So Mr. Dow?
>> Troy Dow: Just two
thoughts very quickly.
One is-- I think this goes to Mr.
Williams' point that this notion
of interoperability-- I don't
know what Mr. Geiger's company
does either.
But just listening to
him, I have every belief
that what he does is in good faith.
But what we've seen even in
some of the CSS litigation is
that we've had people who've tried
to take advantage of the exceptions
for things like security
testing and interoperability,
but things that really were just
about removing content protection
from movies and other entertainment.
And so, unfortunately--
>> Regan Smith: And so, in those
instances, they're doing it
in the name of research or how
do they link that together?
>> Troy Dow: Well, so for
example, in the Corley case,
you had a defense that
was put forward that said
that what was going on there was
really just a matter of trying
to make DVDs interoperable
with Linux computer systems
because they said there
wasn't a Linux player
that could play those DVDs.
In fact, there were licensed
Linux players at the time.
But the problem was that
the way they preferred
to make those movies
viewable on a Linux player was
to remove the copy protection.
Remove the encryption so they
would play on any player, right?
That makes the movie
interoperable by making sure
that there are no protections,
right?
Now, the court saw through that and
didn't see the permanent exemption
as applicable in that circumstance.
But it was an example of
somebody who was not a good actor
who was trying to leverage some of
these exemptions for purposes other
than the ones that were intended.
And we need to be mindful of
the ability of people to do
that in the way they're crafted.
The second point I was going
to make, and this is sort
of probably taking my Disney
hat off and putting back
on my former Judiciary Committee
counsel hat, that this interaction
between Mr. Geiger and Mr. Mohr
I think just highlights the fact
that these exceptions in
the statute were very,
very carefully negotiated,
down to every word
between the relevant
impacted parties.
If we just start going through
and crossing out words, we start--
we start upending a
balance that was struck.
Now, whether or not
this balance continues
to work today is a
totally separate question.
But the notion that somehow we
could just start rejiggering things
and that we would maintain
the type of balance
that was maintained
I think is a concern.
If Mr. Mohr and Mr.
Geiger go off and figure
out what the right
modifications are to it
and it doesn't implicate the types
of concerns I was referring to,
that may be another thing.
But I think this sort of counsels
towards a consensus-based approach
to these things.
>> Kevin Amer: Ms. Koberidze?
>> Maryna Koberidze: I wanted
to pick up on something
that Mr. Love mentioned
regarding European Directive.
Europe went with another
approach than the US.
The US decided to give
fewer exemptions
and to go with rulemaking process.
European Union went with
giving an originally long list
with exemptions.
But some of the countries decided
to provide a mediation process.
And maybe with permanent exemptions
under 1201, that could be an option
for the parties to get into that
mediation process, like we just saw
with Mr. Geiger and Mr. Mohr.
They are open to discussion.
And that would be helpful.
So for example, it could be
like the first step would be
for the interested beneficiary
of the exemption to come forward
and contact the copyright
holder and say,
we would like to make certain uses
under the permanent exemption.
Do you agree or not?
If they do not, then the
intended beneficiaries could go
and request certain agency.
In this case, it would be
Copyright Office to help
to accommodate the access
or third party assistance,
whatever is applicable
in the specific--
under a specific permanent
exemption.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
I do think we need to move on.
I want to turn to talking
about proposals
for new permanent exemptions.
And I wanted to start
with a proposal
that we saw pretty
substantial agreement
on in the written comments.
And that would be an exemption
for the print-disabled
and visually impaired.
As you know, the current exemption
applies to literary works protected
by TPMs that prevent read-aloud
functionality or screen readers
or other assistive technologies.
I would be interested
in your thoughts
about whether Congress
might consider making
that specific exemption permanent.
If so, whether the current
language is sufficient
or whether it should
be altered in some way.
And I'd like to start
with Mr. Cazares.
>> Gabe Cazares: I think that I
first and foremost would be remiss
if I didn't recognize the effort
that both the publishing industry
and the libraries have done in the
last few years to try and ensure
that accessibility is
something that's incorporated
from the beginning.
I think Ms. Cox brought up a
good point on the exemptions
that the libraries really do rely on
to ensure that assistive technology
and other technologies
used by the blind
and visually impaired are available.
And likewise the publishers have
done great work with their members
to ensure that products are
being produced accessibly.
Having said that, I think that
it's safe to say that for people
who are blind and visually impaired,
that circumstance certainly
isn't going to change.
I expect to be blind
three years from now.
So I think that the discussion
is worth having on setting
up a permanent exemption.
I think that the language that
we have now is worth revisiting,
with all of the interested
stakeholders.
Accessibility has been something
that has quite literally
taken a village to try
and bring to the mainstream.
So I think that the discussions
that we've spearheaded,
both with the libraries and the
publishers and the discussion
that we're having now
is a good start.
But I definitely know that
the National Federation
of the Blind is supportive
of such permanent exemption.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
May I ask a follow-up?
I just would be curious to know your
views on sort of how the market--
and you mentioned this at the outset
of your statement-- is responding.
Have you noticed a change over time,
an increase in accessible
format copies becoming available
in the marketplace, such
that, you know, maybe the need
to circumvent may be diminished?
>> Gabe Cazares: So I certainly
don't think that we're at a point
where the need to circumvent
needs to be diminished,
particularly in the
realm of education.
There's still a lot of work
that needs to be done to ensure
that eBooks and digital books that
are produced particularly with,
you know, the DRM, are accessible.
What we're finding now is that a
lot of time authorized entities have
to then take such materials and
ensure that they're accessible.
I think that we're doing-- we're
making significant progress.
But I don't think we're
at the happy-go-lucky day
where I can safely
say that everything
that is produced digitally,
particularly in the literary realm,
is accessible from the beginning.
>> Kevin Amer: Great.
Thank you.
Ms. Cox?
>> Krista L. Cox: So, you've heard
me say earlier, but, of course,
we agree with the position of the
National Federation of the Blind
that these permanent
exemptions are necessary.
And I would just add a few points,
that as the Obama administration
earlier this year submitted the
Marrakesh Treaty for
ratification by the Senate,
also submitted implementing
legislation, it's really important
to note that if the Marrakesh
Treaty comes into force,
that in order to comply with the
treaty and really make it useful,
it would be good to have
that permanent exemption
to ensure compliance
with the treaty.
Additionally, as Mr. Cazares
pointed out, that even though, yes,
there are more works being
produced digitally, it doesn't mean
that those works are
necessarily accessible,
especially in the educational realm.
Our libraries work very often with
the disability services offices
to ensure that we are able
to provide accessible formats
of various textbooks,
which are often not created
in an accessible format
from the start.
You know, we would
love for everything
to be immediately accessible for
our users that are print-disabled.
But that's simply not
the case today.
And just, you know,
I think the example
of the print-disabled also ties into
this question of interoperability
because oftentimes individuals
with print disabilities have a
specific device that they use.
And while it might be accessible on
one format on, you know, an iPad,
it might not be accessible
on a Kindle.
And it's really unfair to ask
someone who is print-disabled
to buy five different devices to
find the one that works for them.
And this actually came up, I
believe, in the rulemaking process
where the joint reply comments from
rights holders groups like the AAP,
MPAA, RIAA criticized
the American Federation
for the Blind's evidence showing
that four of the five works
that they looked at were
not accessible to them.
They actually found that three
of those four were accessible.
They just weren't accessible
on the format that--
and the platform that was being
used to test this in the evidence.
So I think it's really
important to ensure that,
especially for the print-disabled,
that you're not restricting
that exemption.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Ms. Besek?
>> Regan Smith: Microphone.
>> June M. Besek: This is an
appropriate area for Congress to act
because I think the history
of the rulemaking indicates
that this is an exemption that's
regularly been sought and granted
without a lot of opposition.
And I think there's strong public
policy reasons for raising it
to the level of a permanent
exemption.
So, I would favor it in general.
Although, you know, I
can't say sitting here
that the exact formulation,
you know,
of a past rulemaking
is the correct one.
And that's something that
we would have to look at.
I do have some concerns
about the, you know,
accessibility discussion
that we just had.
And, you know, because there's
also the other side of the coin.
You don't want to discourage
the market
for creating accessible versions
for other types of devices as well.
So, there are both sides
of that to consider.
>> Regan Smith: Do you have a
view as to whether a discussion
about implementing a permanent
exemption along this line should be
limited towards sort of
the general subject matter
of the prior exemptions for
the print-disabled as opposed
to accessibility or assistive
technology more broadly?
I mean, we've received
written comments
of an organization
representing individuals
with degenerative diseases,
not necessarily related--
so, not necessarily related
to eBooks or, you know,
accessing books, but
maybe, you know,
playing a videogame, for example.
>> June M. Besek: At this
point, I think because part
of my rationale is
that there has been--
there have been a series of
exemptions already granted,
I would mean the print-disabled.
That doesn't mean that other
groups couldn't seek in the future,
you know, an exemption
under the rulemaking.
And perhaps at some point, you know,
that that would be deemed worthy
of a permanent exemption.
But I think it would be
premature to do that right now.
>> Kevin Amer: Mr. Williams?
>> Matt Williams: Thank you.
I think we would agree that this is
an important exemption that's been
in existence now for some time.
I think you're also right to say
that there's generally consensus
that it should continue
to exist and be renewed.
And at this point in time,
the market isn't adequately
addressing the problem
and that's why we don't oppose
the existence of the exemption.
I think the streamlined
renewal process, again,
is something that would be more
effective at addressing this
than trying to make the exemption
permanent for a couple of reasons.
The first is my understanding
is that there are formats
in development that
are going to roll
out that will make this
problem much less significant
if it doesn't go away.
There's EPUB-3 and HTML-5 which
I understand are both going
to help address these issues.
And so, if that were the case
and circumvention became unnecessary
then there wouldn't be a need
to have an exemption sitting in the
statute when we could just renew it
through the rulemaking process.
The other issue is that if the
language does need to be revisited,
I think that's something
that we would be open to.
But I don't think I've
seen any specific proposals
about how that needs to be done.
So that's something
that could be worked
out before the next rulemaking
or during the next rulemaking.
If we could come to consensus,
we could address what the
changes are that need to be made.
And again, if you put it in the
statute as it currently is drafted
or in some new slightly revised
form, then that's how it will be.
And the rulemaking, the benefit of
it is it's more flexible than that.
You can revisit it.
You can figure out, well, if
it's not fixing the problem,
let's get together
and fix the problem.
So that's I think the
better way to address it.
>> Kevin Amer: Although, I mean,
a permanent exemption
wouldn't preclude, you know,
future requests administratively.
>> Matt Williams: No,
I agree with that.
But I also question
whether it makes sense to go
through the whole legislative
process
of putting new permanent
exemptions into the statute
when it's unlikely they're going to
end up being the ultimate solution.
And I think that's why Congress
created this rulemaking is
that it knew there's going to
be a lot of things that come
up that we can't address
in the statute.
And so, you know, the Title
17 is very long already.
And if we start putting
new things in it
that very quickly become irrelevant
or become no longer capable
of addressing the problems,
then I don't find--
I don't think that that's a
helpful way to go about it.
>> Regan Smith: So, I hear you, but
Congress also implemented a variety
of exceptions to the
prohibition on circumvention,
which are these permanent
exemptions.
I mean, should we treat these on par
with a continuously
renewed exemption or,
you know, where is the line?
Why have one for encryption but not
have one for assistive technology?
>> Matt Williams: Sure.
And I think you have to assess
every issue as it comes up.
As I was saying earlier,
I think a lot
of the permanent exemptions appear
to have largely done their job
and that litigation is not taking
place that results in bad outcomes.
And I think there's a lot of
people who seem to have concerns
about the scope of these exemptions.
But there's not a lot of evidence
that if it actually got litigated,
they wouldn't have
addressed the problem.
But that being said, the fact
that no one is content with them
to me indicates that no matter how
we work through over the next couple
of years creating new permanent
exemptions, someone's going
to figure out a reason
why in a couple
of years they're worried
they're not going to work right.
And they're going to come
to you with those concerns.
And so, I feel like that
renders the legislative work
that everyone would have
to do a little more suspect
because there's already a
process that, as I said yesterday,
is working quite well
where the Office is able
to address these things.
And if you can get them renewed
in a much less burdensome fashion,
that to me is far preferable to
going with the legislative route.
>> Kevin Amer: Mr. Love?
>> James Love: I don't know if
you're aware of this, but we spent--
I spent maybe five years of my
life working about half-time
on this, you know, on this issue.
So we've followed the debates on it.
I'd call attention to-- I
mean, if you look at the--
certainly, the temporary thing
has been a problem for the groups.
There's been years when almost
no evidence was provided
for the renewal, just because it
was such a burdensome proceeding.
And it would have been-- And
there was a recommendation
by the professional staff
to get rid of the exception
because the burden had been met
in the administrative proceeding.
But I think the Library of Congress
wisely extended the exception anyhow
because it recognized that it was
just such a failure of the process
and that the need was still there.
So, I think the idea of having a
permanent exception is appealing,
or at least a more durable
exception in some ways.
The language in the treaty
that people have referred to,
which says that the-- that you
shall take appropriate measures
to make sure that beneficiary
persons can enjoy the limitations
of the exceptions that they
should have, is kind of the level
of generality where
maybe the specifics
of how that's done could be
done more administratively.
I'm sympathetic to the idea
that rigid statutory
frameworks are not necessarily
that appealing in a lot of cases.
I know that there was an
earlier exception for the blind
that had a commercial
availability provision in it.
And there was a letter on the
21st of September, 2012 from NTIA
to Maria Pallante that
discussed this issue.
And some of this is I
think described in a note
that Krista Cox is the
author of June 17th, 2013,
Marrakesh note number four,
when Krista was working with us,
was addressing this issue.
And I would recommend that memo
because I think it's
quite well-written
and I think it's informative
on this point.
But it's-- The finding by NTIA was
that the interoperability problem
had gotten worse, not better.
The hopes was-- We always hear
these talks, you're not going to--
you know, licensing
will solve the problem,
technology will solve the
problem, blah, blah, blah, blah.
But then, the thing that Krista
mentioned earlier about the cost
of obtaining different devices--
also in the context of the treaty,
you saw people making
these presentations
in the treaty negotiations
that would get up
and they would show you what
was considered to be accessible.
Like one blind person from South
Africa, he had had a PDF reader.
It would read an entire page
of text to him in the sort
of permitted format that they
had accessibility where again,
he was just trying to get the
footnote at the bottom of the page.
And he'd try and copy it
down after he'd hear it.
And then, he'd have to start it
again and again and he'd have
to do it like several
different times
because the reader he was using
didn't allow him to stop or cut
and paste and things like that.
Whereas other readers that people
were using were designed more
functionality and were
really easier to use
and more effective for people.
Not only could you speed
up the process quite a bit,
but you had other abilities to sort
of utilize the text
in different ways.
I think people that are not
really familiar with it--
I wasn't that familiar with
it myself and I started
to learn about these things.
Just don't really understand
how high tech some
of the assistive technologies really
are and how idiosyncratic they are
for the users and things like that.
So, for that reason, NTIA
really changed its position
on the commercial availability
because they just didn't think it
was really a workable standard.
Now, that said, I think this balance
between having a permanent mandate
to do something that makes
people unequal in the way
that you're supposed to
is the right approach.
And then, being able to
fine tune the details
of how the exception is implemented
over time, probably a good idea.
My mother's deaf.
She was one of the people who was
excluded from the Marrakesh Treaty
because the motion
picture industry insisted
on that in the negotiations.
Her situation's better today than it
was in the old days because we used
to have to buy separate
devices to do kind of captioning
and now you can get that more--
even Netflix has it these
days, which is kind of nice.
But it is the case that it
was I think a disappointment
that the Marrakesh Treaty on
print disabilities was as narrow.
It was a political decision.
But it also permitted countries
to implement them more widely.
And I think US law is
wider in a lot of areas,
certainly in the area of education.
So I think that striking the right
balance as to how inclusive it is,
but also recognizing that maybe
the exceptions are maybe better
understood in some areas
of disabilities in terms
of the overall effect on all the
stakeholders is probably accurate
as well.
So, you know, I think maybe--
sort of arguing against
myself a little bit--
like sort of maybe sort of
giving like kind of like--
accepting that you sort of know
what you're doing in some areas
and you know you should be
doing something in other areas,
but maybe you're not quite
as confident you know what
that thing is just yet
is probably realistic.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
I think we're going
to go to Ms. Koberidze
and then back to Mr. Cazares.
>> Maryna Koberidze: I believe
there is a strong support
for a permanent exemption
for print-disabled people.
And we have rulemaking
records since 2003.
We have case law, Authors
Guild v. HathiTrust.
We have Chafee amendment and we
have also international obligations
under Marrakesh Treaty.
And although despite
all these regulations,
print-disabled people still
cannot benefit from the exemptions
that are granted within
the rulemaking proceedings.
And this is because
they need accessibility
and they need third
party assistance.
And I think it would
be very important
when we consider permanent exemption
to consider these two issues,
how to facilitate accessibility
and how
to facilitate third
party assistance.
Whether it will be through
mediation process, as I mentioned,
with the copyright holders
or whether it will be
with help of the Copyright Office.
Or maybe, there could
be a third solution
to create a separate
management organization similar
to Sound Exchange in the
music industry which will help
to manage third party
assistance issues.
Thank you.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you very much.
Mr. Cazares?
>> Gabe Cazares: I
think that a couple
of great points have been made.
I agree in part with Mr. Williams.
I think that the forthcoming of
EPUB-3 and HTML-5 are going to kind
of revolutionize the way
accessibility is approached
in the mainstream.
But I also want to address the
fact of the permanent exemption.
The fact is that people with
disabilities, particularly the AFB,
the American Foundation
for the Blind
and other folks have been requesting
exemptions that have been,
by and large, being renewed
with little to no opposition
because the circumstances
really don't change
for people with disabilities.
I think given the notion-- the
fact that we have a large number
of people who are blind
or visually impaired
in this country alone
guarantees a permanent exemption.
I don't see the need, until
the process is reformed,
for the renewal-- the
rulemaking process,
I don't see the reason why
people with disabilities,
people who are print-disabled have
to go through the burdensome process
of requesting for and waiting
to be granted another
three-year exemption.
I think that this particular
circumstance, given the situation
of blind and print-disabled
Americans,
warrants a permanent exemption.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you very much.
I think we have quite
broad agreement
on that topic, which is encouraging.
We have-- We're getting
close to the end.
And so, I think we just had
one or two sort of suggestions
for permanent exemptions that we
wanted to ask your views about.
One proposal that came
up in the comments was
to make the current
unlocking exemption permanent.
We'd be interested in your views
on the advisability of that.
Mr. Dow?
>> Troy Dow: So, I think it was
Mr. Adler in the previous panel
who read some from the legislative
history and the contextual part
of the unlocking-- the circumstances
of the unlocking legislation.
And I think that that
counsels towards an approach
that says a permanent
exception for that type
of thing is really
not the way to go.
And I think that's not
unique to unlocking per se.
I think that really
applies when you're dealing
with very technologically
specific items in general.
But the one thing on the unlocking
legislation specifically was
that the unique circumstances
of that was
that we knew what that meant.
We knew what it meant
to unlock a phone.
We knew that what it meant was
the entry of a code, right?
It was a handful of digits
that could be entered in.
And the only thing that resulted
from the entry of those digits was
that you could connect
that phone to a network.
It didn't expose the
content on the phone.
It didn't expose personal
information.
There weren't privacy
interests that were affected.
There weren't copyright interests.
It was a very narrow thing.
But we didn't know what
that was going to mean
for the next device, right?
I mean, that was one of the
issues that we talked about,
should this be expanded
into the context of tablets
and other computing devices, right?
Does circumvention for the purposes
of connecting the device mean
the same thing in those contexts?
Does it mean simply that you can
connect that device to a network
or does it mean that all of a
sudden, it does implicate some
of these other interests
that didn't exist at the time
of the cell phone unlocking
legislation?
And so, I think the legislative
history speaks specifically to that.
It talks about that being
a unique circumstance
and why Congress was
comfortable doing it.
And I think it speaks towards why,
in the context of trying to look
at that for other devices
and in other contexts,
it really requires a specific focus
and one that's uniquely suited
to something like the rulemaking as
opposed to the legislative process
and the permanent exemption.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Love? Oh, that was from before?
OK. Anyone else want to weigh in?
Ms. Koberidze?
>> Maryna Koberidze: I
support this type of exemption,
although I understand it will be
very hard to agree on the language,
especially since, as was mentioned a
lot today, new devices are coming in
and it's very hard to predict
what kind of users and what kind
of uses will need to be exempted.
But we need to start
discussing it now
because as the last
rulemaking showed,
it will be-- it was the beginning.
All those devices, smartphones,
TVs and medical devices.
Now, we will have Amazon Alexa
and then we will have smart homes.
And everything will be connected.
And a lot of security
testing would be needed.
A lot of privacy issues will arise.
And those will not be concerned
with the copyright law by itself,
but because a lot of those devices
and technologies use
copyrighted material,
which is computer programs,
it would be helpful
to at least start drafting
some permanent exemption
that will help us to start
moving in that direction
of unlocking certain
devices for certain uses.
Maybe, it would be
very narrowly tailored.
But we can at least use the
rulemaking record to find
out which ones are more
important to make now.
>> Regan Smith: Can I ask
just one follow-up question?
Then I think we're going to
move to another proposal.
But just should we consider
the specific narrow case
of unlocking your phones differently
than the broader jail-breaking
classes, right, where you're opening
up an activity-- you
know, host your devices,
the technology may work differently,
sort of going to Mr. Dow's point.
And we may not know exactly what
software is being implicated
for that?
Should we treat unlocking
differently than jail-breaking?
>> Maryna Koberidze: Yeah.
What I'm talking about,
unlocking, it means I'm trying
to just cover all the aspects,
including car tinkering
and including jail-breaking.
I don't expect those-- all
of those could be even become
permanent exemptions.
But, at least, wireless
devices, just unlocking,
to be able to change carriers.
And it's interesting how the
rulemaking itself resulted
in changes on the marketplace
because now, even if we look
at the Amazon Alexa, the system is
open to third party applications.
And we don't-- might
not need jail-breaking
for that specific device.
But changing-- at least
changing carriers,
I think it could be very helpful
to have for the mobile devices.
>> Regan Smith: OK.
So I think I'll go to Mr.
Williams next and then, I think,
in your answer, you sort of
open up where we were going
to go next anyways, which is sort
of repair and auto tinkering.
So, if you would like to
comment on that, also feel free,
since we're running short on time.
>> Maryna Koberidze: Thank you.
>> Regan Smith: Mr. Williams?
>> Matt Williams: Thank you.
Just on your last question about
how to handle jail-breaking,
I would be opposed to trying
to create a permanent exemption
for jail-breaking for the reasons
that Mr. Dow expressed
related to unlocking.
And also because even within
the context of the rulemaking,
there have been things referred
to as jail-breaking proposed
that the Office has concluded
should not be granted.
And going back to what I referred
to earlier and Mr. Dow referred to,
the Linux situation with DVDs,
there are a number of times
that people have sought
to impress on the Office
that they were entitled to
access an expressive work
on any device of their choice.
And the Office has
concluded that's not correct.
And so, to try to craft
a permanent exemption
for jail-breaking the things
that the Office has concluded,
you should be able to jail-break,
but not sweeping in the things
that you've already concluded
you should not be able to hack
and then also address future devices
and future products and services.
I think that would be
a very unworkable task.
So I'd be opposed to that.
>> Regan Smith: OK.
Thank you.
Mr. Love, and I'd ask you to keep it
short, just because we are running
out of time for all of
our next commenters.
>> James Love: Right now, the
Copyright Office is the decider
on a lot of these things.
And then, other agencies
petition the Copyright Office
with their concerns.
In the FDA proceedings right now,
there's been requests that the FDA
as a regulatory thing regulate some
of the technical protection measures
on medical devices as part of
a broader work they're doing
on medical devices and hospital
networks in terms of cybersecurity.
I'm just wondering if in
some cases, it makes sense
for the Copyright Office
to farm out some--
like in the jail-breaking
case, I mean, maybe the--
I'm not sure that it makes
sense for the Copyright Office
to be the be all and end all
of the decision-making in terms
of future way you might
imagine doing.
Or should this be something that you
envision that other agencies could--
I mean, does it always have to
be your rulemaking authority
or could another agency
basically be--
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
I mean, I do take your point and
in fact, in the last rulemaking,
the Copyright Office did solicit
some viewpoints from other agencies
when commenters had suggested that
it may fall under their bailiwick.
I think the discussion
of jail-breaking is getting a little
fuzzy, whereas in the rulemakings,
it's been referred to
opening up a device in order
to install different apps on it.
So it wouldn't-- that
wouldn't necessarily extend
to medical devices.
But I do take your point.
And Mr. Mohr?
>> Chris Mohr: Just quickly, I
mean, I think, you know, we--
SIIA has had some experience
with trying to move I think
in hindsight a bit too quickly.
So, we were supporters of UCITA
and I was not representing them,
but I was at many of
those drafting meetings.
And what you had was somebody
trying to draft a statute
that codified practice that would
literally change every two months.
We would have new language
proposed because AOL did something
or CompuServe did something.
And it just never stayed still.
And I think in terms of for
a lot of the kinds of things
that we are talking
about that the type
of flexibility particularly
with, as Mr. Williams mentioned,
the kind of streamlining
which we've discussed
and which enjoys pretty
broad support, with that type
of flexibility, I think you will
produce better policy results.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
I know we're running out of time.
I have one final question.
Others may have other
questions about just some
of the other permanent
exemptions, if anyone wanted
to weigh in on them, there's one.
For example, for privacy, you know,
if we can beat the hypothetical
to death right now, is
it working if you want
to turn off your smart refrigerator
so it doesn't spy on you
or protection of minors,
analog devices.
There's one for federal agencies.
Does anyone else want to comment
on potential reforms to those?
Mr. Perry?
>> David M. Perry: I
thought you'd never ask.
So--
>> Kevin Amer: We appreciate
your patience.
>> David M. Perry: That's OK.
I won't repeat what was said
in the previous sessions.
And our client is a player in
the auto after-market industry.
You know, we haven't-- to be honest,
I talked at length with our client
about permanent-- the
permanency of the exemption.
I think it's-- and I'm not really
sure what a streamlined renewal
process would be as
distinguished from permanent,
exactly how it would work.
I think if we liked the exemption,
we would want it to be permanent.
We don't like this
exemption as it's written so,
we haven't spoken about
it very much.
The class 21 exemption, as I pointed
out in the prior session, you know,
sort of morphed from as it was
proposed to as it ended up.
And some of the wording in
there with respect to on behalf
of the owner or authorized owner,
you know, some of the wording
in the exemption essentially
for the, you know,
$200 billion auto after-market
industry sort
of left them basically hanging.
If you-- And a point I did not
make in the prior session was
and this may be the only
exemption of all the classes,
the class 21 exemption
really doesn't kick
in for I think 12 months from when
it was originally promulgated.
And it also has an explicit sort
of directive over to the DOT
and the EPA, which sort
of ties in with a point
that Mr. Geiger made earlier about,
you know, those laws are there.
Do we need to have
the Copyright Office
in an exemption essentially give
sort of a tentative shout-out
over to the DOT and the EPA
saying we just want to make sure
that what we're doing here isn't
going to violate your laws.
So, just to be safe, let's not make
any of this happen for 12 months.
And the effective result, at least
for the after-market industry,
was to basically look at
this exemption and say, well,
that basically didn't
really give us much
of anything except maybe
another year to wait
and see what litigation
is going to ensue,
what kind of lobbying
is going to take place.
And, you know, if you're, however,
if you are a car repair enthusiast,
starting, I guess, in October of
next year, if you want to circumvent
and fix your windshield wipers and
break into the chip that exists
in there, I suppose this
exemption is for you.
The reality is that it doesn't
help the average person.
It doesn't help any of us, the
average person who drives a car
who goes to their local mechanic,
which is about I think 70%
of automobile after-market
repair is done through,
you know, your local mechanic.
It's not done at the dealer.
Of course, this ties in hugely
to automobile manufacturers
and big auto and all the
tensions between the automakers
and their own dealers, where there's
great tension, the after-market,
where there's additional tension.
And to Mr. Mohr's point earlier,
I mean, I think we fully agree,
the expression versus function--
functionality, that
dichotomy, it's not easy.
It's not easy at all.
Some cases I think with cars
are easier to see than others
if you're talking about a windshield
wiper or a door, you know,
the button that turn, you
know, brings your windows down.
But there are a lot of grey areas
in this so sort of a long answer
to address a variety of
issues that came up earlier.
But this particular exemption
in class 21 is so watered down
and tentative that there's
no reason for us to want this
to be permanent as written.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Ms. Koberidze?
>> Maryna Koberidz:
I just wanted to add
that even ask whether the wording
in our permanent exemptions subject
to privacy and security and other
regulations will resolve the
concerns expressed today and earlier
in the roundtable regarding
privacy issues and safety issues.
So, will it give some
deference to other agencies
who are best positioned
to address those issues?
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Love, and then Mr. Dow,
and I think then we're going
to open it up to the audience.
>> James Love: If it was possible,
we would think it would be useful
if the Copyright Office would
have a permanent exception in this
to the extent of remedies to
anticompetitive practices.
Or possibly you mentioned privacy,
maybe that's another area too
that the Federal Trade
Commission would spell out.
And it's like sort of the idea
of not just having this office
but maybe kind of a
decentralized area where,
in addition to whatever
you do, that another agency
such as the Federal
Trade Commission,
which deals with anticompetitive
practices
and interoperability issues on
a regular basis may play a role.
Also, I said this earlier in terms
of medical devices for the FDA,
I think if the FDA asserts some
kind of role in the area of security
of medical devices and networks,
I think that they should be able
to extend the benefits
of an exception.
And then, I think that
should be kind
of be hardwired into the process.
And the last thing I would
say, the final thing would be
on the National Science Foundation.
I think they should be able to
make similar recommendations
as it relates to artificial
intelligence systems,
which a topic which we addressed
in some of our comments earlier.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
And I just wanted to make clear,
currently under the statute 1201(i)
is an exemption in the Copyright Act
for the protection of personally
identifying information.
So that's an existing
place to either accept,
build off from, et cetera.
>> Kevin Amer: Mr. Dow?
>> Troy Dow: OK, just very quickly.
One thing that I think
we really haven't touched
on has been the incentive value
of the rulemaking process.
The rulemaking process
in part was adopted
to give copyright owners
an incentive
to use technological
protection measures,
to apply them to protect
their works in ways
that can accommodate non-infringing
uses because there was this process
that said if you use these
things in ways that cut
out non-infringing uses and impair
that, then there's the likelihood
that you will wind up with
an exception that's going
to allow people to hack into your
technological protection measures,
an incentive built in there
to try and be responsible
about the way you apply these.
And I think we've seen some of that.
There was a comment I
think a few minutes ago
about maybe some movement that
we have seen in the market
for accessibility and perhaps
having something to do with some
of the rulemaking proceedings
with respect to unlocking,
and how that may have driven
the marketplace in some ways.
Whether we're talking in security
research, whether we're talking
in unlocking a and jail-breaking,
whether we're talking in licensing
and we heard Mr. Turnbull earlier
talk about the willingness to talk
about solutions to provide licensed
mechanisms to achieve these things
because the backstop alternative
really isn't appealing.
The rulemaking process,
the ongoing nature of it,
provides those incentives.
The permanent exceptions really
don't provide those incentives.
If you have a permanent exception,
the incentive is really to say, OK,
well I guess we have nothing there.
That's just the way it is
and there's no incentive
to work going forward.
So, I think it's just worth
remembering that there was a purpose
to be served in the incentive
nature of the rulemaking.
I think it works.
I think it had some impact and
I think there's value to it.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
We are overtime.
So I think we're going to
have to leave it there.
Thank you all very much.
This was very helpful.
And now, our final session is an
audience participation session.
We have a microphone at the back.
Oh, here it is at the front.
And so, if you have signed up,
you're welcome to come forward
and ask any questions or
make any comments either
about this particular topic or any
of the topics that
we've talked about.
>> And you can still sign up.
>> Kevin Amer: And
you can still sign up.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Regan Smith: Do we have
anybody who's already signed
up who wishes to speak?
No? All right, all right.
Head on up.
>> Kevin Amer: And if you
could just-- yeah, right.
>> Brandon Butler: I can lean down.
>> Kevin Amer: If you could
just identify yourself?
I know who you are.
>> Brandon Butler: Yes, of course.
Absolutely.
Brandon Butler, from the
University of Virginia Library.
I just wanted to chime in.
Earlier, there was a discussion
about the scope of Section 108
and a question of whether in the
context of preservation activities,
one would need to necessarily
violate the ban on circumvention
for purposes of copying as
distinct for purposes of access.
And the answer is absolutely yes.
Best practices for preservation
and for access include
to make multiple copies
in different formats,
often in different locations
so that, you know, for example,
you don't want to be pulling up an
emulator of an outdated DRM thing
and the original file every time a
researcher wants to read that thing
that was on Salman Rushdie's laptop.
What you would do is do that
once, export that content
into an access copy and then try
not to ever have to do that again
so that all that stuff stays safe
and not changed by the processes
that you're applying in
order to preserve the thing.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you very much.
>> Brandon Butler: And
can I say one other thing?
>> Kevin Amer: Sure.
>> Brandon Butler: Because I
was not on the earlier panel
about the first panel yesterday,
I wanted to weigh in a little bit
about the question of competition
issues and non-copyright interests
that come into play in
the context of 1201.
Someone mentioned earlier
on this panel, I think,
the notion that other agencies
should be able to weigh in.
And I just wanted to agree with
that, that if the question is,
you know, if we're really thinking
about overhauling the whole 1201
system, changing the legislation,
not just thinking what can we do
without changing the legislation,
it would be great to have, you know,
the agencies that really know
cars be the ones that drive
so to speak the process
that has to do with cars.
>> Regan Smith: Great.
I mean, I hate to put you on
the spot during open mic time
but currently, there is
consultation with NTIA
and other agencies can
participate in the rulemaking.
I think you saw a lot
of them did reach
out to the Copyright
Office or we solicited them.
So, you know, so is it broken and
in need of fixing or is it sort
of working and you're
just saying I acknowledge
that this is happening
and that's OK?
>> Brandon Butler: I think there is
a real risk that where the interests
at the heart of the issue are, you
know, car safety or consumer safety
or competition, that having
an agency that deals routinely
with copyright issues
and with people who care
about copyright issues in the
driver's seat consulting the people,
but ultimately the last word is
in the copyright relevant
agency seems maybe
like something that is not ideal.
If we could move the driver's
seat over to the other agency
and then they would consult with
you so you could weigh in and say,
you know, no, there's not a problem
for the copyright industries,
the primarily copyright-oriented
industries.
This is about cars.
It would make more sense for them
to control and to consult you
than the other way around.
>> Regan Smith: Yes, and I think
the Office has probably, you know,
in our defense, has tried to
stick to the copyright interests
or thinking of it under the title,
you know, of the Copyright Act.
But that's good to consider.
>>Harley Geiger: Can I
make a quick point on that,
which is that we're not
really seeing the agencies
that have relevant expertise in
these areas hold back either.
So it's not as if though 1201
is keeping these agencies at bay
and they're not issuing
their own regulations
or their own legislative
proposals to enhance car safety
or prevent hacking or
circumvention because of 1201.
In many cases, we're
seeing both move forward.
In the case of the FDA, they
just released their after-market
cybersecurity guidelines
for medical devices.
We saw NHTSA come out with--
or at least support legislation
that would have addressed
hacking in cars.
So it's unclear to us why-- like
what benefit 1201 is serving
for these agencies if they're coming
forward with their own proposals
or in many cases, have
existing regulations anyway.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Adler?
>> Allan Adler: At the
moment, my name is the only one
on that sheet back
there, just so you know.
>> Kevin Amer: Oh, OK.
[ Laughter ]
>> Allan Adler: Yes, I just wanted
to make an additional comment,
the discussion about the
accessibility exemption I think was
very interesting when we,
as Mr. Williams indicated,
do think that if we get the
streamlining process right
for renewal, that renewal
with respect
to the exemption is more
appropriate for all the reasons
that were mentioned about
flexibility, and particularly
because of the fact that
the market is changing.
It's not changing fast enough.
It hasn't changed to the point
where it is satisfactory.
But it is continuing to change.
And that's the reason why commercial
availability was always discussed
as an exception to the
exception, even when we talk
about the Chafee Amendment.
And I would point out that,
for example, the importance
of access controls cuts in
many different directions.
For example, we helped to validate
the legitimacy of Bookshare,
which was an authorized entity under
the terms of the Chafee Amendment
that became the first
authorized entity to exist online,
and to be able to provide access to
accessible format copies of works
in digital forms on
a subscriber basis.
And we supported that
and it was worth pointing
out that Bookshare uses access
controls such as encryption
to make sure that when these
materials are being delivered
to beneficiary persons who
are entitled to use them,
who need the accessible
format copies
that they're being
delivered to the right people.
I would also point out that
there was a lot of discussion
about the Marrakesh Treaty.
With respect to the TPM
provision of the Marrakesh Treaty,
it's generally the view
that US law already complies
with that language precisely
because of the exemption
that has been created and renewed
in the 1201 rulemaking process,
as well as a result of the
Chafee amendment itself.
But with respect to the comment
I just made about Bookshare,
I would also just point out
that there's an agreed statement
that goes along with the
Marrakesh Treaty, that in referring
to the TPM section, specifically
says that because the ability
to transport across national
borders accessible format copies
of works is what the treaty
provides for and intends to be able
to facilitate, this
language was agreed upon.
It's understood that to distribute
or make available accessible
format copies directly
to a beneficiary person in
another contracting party,
it may be appropriate
for an authorized entity
to apply further measures to confirm
that the person it is serving
is a beneficiary person
and to follow its own practices
as described in the article
that delineates what an
authorized entity is.
So, access controls are going
to be important in order
for the Marrakesh Treaty
to be a success,
to make sure that not only can
accessible format copies be
delivered across national
borders all around the world
from an authorized entity
in one country to another,
but as the treaty also provides,
from authorized entities
in one country directly
to beneficiary persons
in another country without having
to have the intercession
of an authorized entity.
So, I would also just mention that
we have emphasized the importance
of making sure that people
understand what an authorized entity
is, that an authorized
entity indeed is willing
to undertake what is necessary to
make the Marrakesh Treaty a success
and to facilitate its
purposes properly.
And I hope that we will have support
from that with respect to others
who commented favorably on
the notion of the importance
of an accessibility
exemption in the 1201 process.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you very much.
>> Derek Manners: Hello.
My name is Derek Manners.
I'm from the National
Federation for the Blind as well.
I just wanted to comment briefly.
I think there's a lot of agreement
that the accessibility
exemption is important.
I think it's nice to hear that
we're sort of debating about how
to best preserve it, how to
make it easier for everybody.
And I think there's
widespread agreement about that.
One point I would like to make
though is that Mr. Williams
in particular indicated that the
rulemaking process encouraged
parties to work together.
And I don't think that a permanent
exemption would discourage parties
from continuing to work together
in particular because many
of the entities, third party
entities that have been discussed
that have to make things
accessible for the blind
and for the disabled have
legal obligations to do
so under Sections 504
of the Rehab Act
and Titles II and III of the ADA.
And so, there will be a continuous
dialogue on how to make sure
that that's done well because they
have a legal obligation to do so.
And that's going to require
buy-in also from the publishers
and manufacturers to make
sure that it's not being
like Mr. Adler was talking about,
that there are controls to make sure
that it's not, you
know, being abused
or that copies aren't
getting leaked out.
And so, I don't think that the
permanent exemption would be--
would preclude continued efforts
to work together to ensure
that blind people have access
to accessible material while
still protecting the interest
of the stakeholders.
Thank you.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you very much.
Did you?
>> Krista L. Cox: Yeah, I just--
I mean, I wanted to clarify that,
you know, I agree with Mr.
Adler that we can comply
with our treaty obligations by
renewing this exemption and ensuring
that this exemption
continues to persist.
My point was simply that having a
permanent exemption really makes a
lot of sense and it would ensure
compliance rather than risk,
you know, at some point that
the exemption is not granted
in the future.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
>> Raza Panjwani: Good afternoon.
Raza Panjwani, from
Public Knowledge.
There are just a few general
comments I wanted to add based
on this panel and some
of the prior panels.
I would encourage the Office,
as it's undergoing this study,
to adopt the lens of asking, what
was the bargain in Section 1201
between rights holders and the
public, and is that bargain
and the assumptions underpinning
that bargain about the marketplace
and the incentives
actually functioning.
And I think a great example
of considering that is
that throughout the discussion,
we've heard some folks say
that we think the exemption
process is working fine.
We think the renewability
discussion is academic.
And most of the folks making those--
taking those positions are the folks
on the rights holders' side.
And I think it's important
to realize,
as Professor Tushnet
put it yesterday,
that there are asymmetries
in the process.
That if the process is falling
short of its goal, for example,
of providing the exemptions that
are necessary to the public,
that leaves the rights holders,
you know, whole in a sense,
that the ban is working,
the 1201(a) prohibition
on circumvention is still working.
You know, the process only
isn't working for them
when the exemptions go too far.
And I think it's worth sort
of noting that because,
especially I think the discussion
about the renewability being
academic, I think is important
to realize because
there have been cases
where exemptions haven't
been renewed.
And I think for those on the
proponent side, it's not academic
that there is a risk of
exemption not being granted,
that the burden is on them
to provide the proof
necessary to get the exemption.
So I don't think that's
an academic discussion.
And finally, on that
point, and especially tying
into the accessibility discussion,
the example that Mr. Love brought
up of footnotes not
being accessible.
That might be a case where
someone might say, well,
95% of literature is accessible.
That's just an edge case.
When you're the user and that
particular case implicates you,
it's not an edge case.
That is a failure of the system.
And I think the exemption
process and the user carve-outs
in the permanent exemptions
aren't meant
to cover those edge
cases in particular.
So I would urge the
Office to consider in terms
of evaluating what the burden of
proof should be, is considering
that edge cases don't necessarily
mean the system is working.
Thank you.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you very much.
Did you have another comment?
No? OK. That's OK.
Anyone else?
Ms. Koberidze
>> Maryna Koberidze: Just a quick
remark regarding accessibility.
So, the rulemaking exemption
for print-disabled people
was renewed since 2003.
Today-- Now, it's 2016 and still,
there is statistics that over 90%
of the books are not available
in the form for print-disabled.
And even tech companies
like Microsoft,
in their comments,
they agree on that.
And they fail and they
acknowledge that they were not able
to accommodate all the needs
of the print-disabled people.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Love?
>> James Love: Well, I want to
mention I was contacted recently
by someone who supported our work
in the past in different areas.
And he asked me a bunch of questions
about artificial intelligence.
And I guess he was following a lot
of things that you're beginning
to see more and more in
the literature of concerns
about the potential, you know,
really almost existential threat
or at least in some peoples minds,
these kind of things represent,
different points of view.
But then, there's like a wider
range of things about just
as we get enveloped
more with software
that we barely understand
what's going on in our lives.
I mean, we're, you know, we're
being told what movies to watch or,
you know, how to drive to work.
I mean, it's just become such a
huge part of our life these days
that this idea that you
need to audit and monitor
and understand better these forces
which are shaping our lives.
I don't think people are
really here to cut up with
like how different life is today
than it was five years ago,
10 years ago or 20
years ago in terms
of the relationship
between us and software.
And I think that it's important
to realize that being able to look
under the-- to have somebody to have
the authority to basically sort of,
you know, take a look under the
hood to sort of see what's going
on is going to become more
important, not less important.
So, to the extent that
you're, you know,
you're making the system
more leaky, not less leaky,
I think that's a good
thing, not a bad thing.
I just wanted to say that.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you very much.
Oh, Mr. Williams?
>> Matt Williams: Thanks.
Briefly, I just wanted to return
quickly to something the gentleman
from Public Knowledge just said
about considering, you know,
is the bargain that was struck
in 1998, is that being met
and are rights holders fulfilling
their end of the bargain.
And I think if you look through the
several pages of our initial filing
in this proceeding and in all
of our rulemaking filings,
you'll see that there is just a vast
array of new products and services
that have hit the market and that my
clients have been meeting their side
of that bargain to the
best of their ability.
And I just wanted to make sure
that that was on the record
that I think consumers
have benefited greatly
from the existence of 1201.
That are all kinds of
products and services
that no one would have
thought would be available,
have been made available.
Thank you.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you very much.
That concludes today's session.
Thank you all very much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.